[Musique]
mua
aïe
alors je m'appelle frédéric dupuy et je
suis prof de cuisine à tour à table donc
société de cours de cuisine pour les
particuliers et les entreprises
depuis 14 ans ce qui m'a donné envie de
faire ce métier c'est ma passion pour la
transmission et pour la pédagogie et à
la fois mon autre passion pour la
cuisine
alors évidemment des souvenirs quand on
travaille dans un
métier conviviale que la cuisine on en a
plein des très bons souvenirs
il y en a un qui m'a vraiment marqué un
jour il ya un cours de cuisine un duo
maman filles qui sont venus une grande à
dos et qui était malade d'anorexie
mentale et en fait j'ai vu la fille la
jeune fille rentrait être très réticente
et petit à petit se détendre et
participer aux cours de cuisine et samaa
fins c'était un moment magique
[Musique]
donc pour la recette du macarons à la
framboise il vous faut 200 g de sucre
glace
112 g de poudre d'amandes 30 g de sucre
normal 90 g de blancs
ça c'est pour la partie biscuits et pour
la partie ganache c'est confiture de
framboises et framboises surgelées
parce que quand elles sont à moitié
décongeler elle s'intègre mieux dans la
confiture donc ensuite qu'il faut faire
c'est tamisée de la poudre d'amandes
avec le sucre glace
monter les blancs en neige les sucrés et
les colorer
[Musique]
et ensuite macaronis l'ensemble donc la
poudre d'amandes le sucre glace à
intégrer dans les blancs en neige monte
et coloré ensuite on va mettre en poche
et on va poser et les macarons
harmonieusement et délicatement sur la
plaque de cuisson
il ya une phase qui est importante c'est
la phase de séchage ou dick routage il
faut que à la surface avant d'enfourner
ayez une petite sensation de sécheresse
vous en toucher quelques-uns effleuré et
si vous sentez que c'est un petit peu
sec
à ce moment là c'est que vous pouvez
informer si vous vous enfourner trop tôt
vous n'aurez pas la partie coque et la
partie collerette de votre macarons qui
se créent au bout de quatre minutes dans
le faire alors voilà on a réalisé les
macarons à la framboise facile à faire
bonne dégustation
oui
plus discret mairie
[Musique]